[Musique]
on a eu un conseil municipal qui était
un conseil municipal je dirais classique
avec bien sûr plusieurs points à l'ordre
du jour dont d'euros le renouvellement
je dirais et l'acceptation du projet en
russe sur les animaux qui était ni plus
ni moins que l'acceptation des 64
millions d'euros qui sont qui vont être
injectés dans le quartier pour des
projets m'a vu débarquer
pas mal de personnes très très très
violemment expressive qui tapait très
fortement sur les portes sur les
fenêtres du conseil municipal puisqu'on
était en visio moi j'étais seul avec des
personnes de l'administration de général
qui d'ailleurs était très apeuré
j'ai porté plainte parce que je
considère qu'en tant que représentant
des habitants en tant que élus de la
république je ne peux pas accepter qu'on
me fasse quand mon encontre parce que je
veux dire c'est geste n'était pas fait
de façon large c'était vraiment me
regardant bien dans les yeux c'est
quelque chose que je ne peux pas
accepter donc les suites je n'en sais
rien
qui a été clair un jeudi qu'il était
hors de question de laisser intimider
par ce genre de choses il était hors de
question d'arrêter ce projet de toute
façon si on devait arrêter ce projet
bien nous perdons les 64 millions
d'euros aujourd'hui on va comme je vous
le disais commencer les vraiment les
négociations et des discussions avec
tout le monde pour parler surtout de
cette fameuse salle associative qui va
être ouverte aux gens du quartier qui en
ont véritablement besoin
[Musique]